all right as we continue from mar-a-lago
my exclusive interview with the 45th
president of the united states donald
trump
i want to know this question what are
your plans
for to help for 2022 we talked about the
house and the states
are you thinking about running again in
2024
and if so where are you in that process
we are going to help with the house i
think we have a really good chance i'm
working with
everybody including kevin mccarthy on
taking back the house
i think we have a really good chance on
doing it likewise the senate is going to
be a little bit tougher
but the senate so i told you that
at least eight senators would have lost
their race i could name them but i don't
want to embarrass
him but that includes mitch
who was heading south he called me up he
said i need your help
and i'm very popular in kentucky i love
kentucky and they love me
and i helped him and he won by the most
he's ever won by
so we are going to help with the senate
i think we have a good chance
marco rubio i hear herschel's name
mentioned a lot in georgia herschel
i hear laura trump's name mentioned a
lot in north carolina sununu in new
hampshire
i think he could win that race ron
johnson in wisconsin ron johnson is a
great outfit a great senator he is a
great he is much more popular than
anybody understanding we don't know
who's going to run in ohio
um but these are some good candidates in
ohio
so i think we have a real chance at the
senate i think we have a really really
good chance
well tell me what how far are you
willing to go are you going to travel
are you going to do speeches are you
going to do rallies for these candidates
if they need a rally we'll do a rally
we'll do
calls we'll do all sorts of things no no
we're all in
uh alabama is going to be a tremendous
win with mo brooks
we have a tremendous look almost
everybody i endorse wins
we had a house seat in louisiana a
wonderful woman you know just happened
her husband died of covet he was
congressman-elect
and she is julia she was fantastic
but a lot of people thought she might
not get in the runoff i endorsed her
she got 65 percent of the vote there was
no runoff
it's very important that we get the
right people and that means in the
senate it means in the house and it also
means in governorships because
if you have a good governor and
legislature state legislatures
well that's so important you know the
legislatures have that's where they're
going to fix the voting issues we've had
a lot of great legislators
unfortunately the courts refuse to
listen even though it's in the
constitution that they have to
the courts have been very hr one i would
i argue
usurps the constitutional authority of
state legislatures
now the big question do you
two parts what do you miss the most
about
being in the white house and how
seriously
are you considering running again in
2024
i miss the most helping people because i
can directly help people that's why i
did it
look this has been a very traumatic i
had a great life
great company great business no problems
and now all i do is people go after you
it's it's vicious it's horrible
but you know what i love doing it
because i help people
and i've helped them more than any
president with the cutting of taxes with
the regulations with
uh right to try you know how big right
to try is
huge where you don't have to travel to
all sorts of different continents to try
and get something we have the greatest
doctors in north greatest labs
we can use their medicines now if
somebody's terminally ill
they can sign a quick little document
you can use med and and that's had a
huge thing what are you most proud of
though
a lot of things uh i'm very proud of the
tax cuts i hope they don't screw it up
because the jobs
you know we brought back i think so we
brought back a
record well it's still not going to be
as high as it was you know it was really
39
right so it looks like it could be a 25
i brought it down to 21.
but i'm very proud of that i'm very
proud of the
and very importantly the regulation cuts
i'm very proud of what i did for the
military i've rebuilt the military
and i've added something called space
force it's going to be so powerful so
important
so i've added another think of it i've
added to the military hasn't happened
since
i guess 75 years since the air force and
the we've added precautions
record low unemployment we had the
greatest numbers in the history of the
world
we had the greatest economy in history
world
we had the greatest economy we had the
greatest job numbers we had the great
we're up to 160 million people we were
never even close to that
and if you think of it i did it twice
because then the whole world went down
we've come back stronger than any other
country in the world
you know they used to hit me with
germany and france and this and that
well they're doing terribly right now
they're all locked down it's a disaster
they're having riots on their streets
this country is coming back strong and
it's very interesting
places like florida and texas
and many others i mean i could name many
others
i think in almost all cases run by
republicans i think in
all cases but they've done so well
and you look i saw the other day
michigan i would say there's been
nothing as close
other than for her husband who was you
know had free run of the place
i don't think that there's been any
state more locked up than michigan
are you running again in 2024 what what
what are the odds
if i were to first of all it's a long
time the odds the odds what are the
others look
the odds i got tremendous numbers
nobody's ever gotten the numbers i got
no sitting presidents come even close
there's more popularity now than there
was the day before the election because
they see how bad things are at the
border they see what's going on they see
that
their guns are going to be gone their
second amendment their taxes are going
up regulations are going through the
roof jobs are going to go out
well you see you know this is going to
take a little while to show but if they
add all these regulations back
the jobs are going to be gone your
energy independence is going to be gone
so i i say this i i am looking at it
very seriously beyond seriously
uh from a legal standpoint i don't want
to really talk about it yet
it's a little too if you did run and did
win
what would you do differently um
when i came in we were hit with phony
russia-russia-russia investigations it
was a total phony deal
that was three years of your presidency
i've been i've been
fighting off investigations for five
years i mean really
since the almost the day that we came
down
and they were corrupt democrat inspired
i still have it
they were democrat-inspired
investigations
russia i remember sean and i don't have
too much time i guess with you but a
story i think it's interesting i haven't
told it before
during the campaign in 2016 i'd be asked
like by one of our aides
sir do you have anything to do with
russia
i say no no that would be it then
a month later somebody would say what do
you know about russia
i said now what i don't know what you're
talking about okay i wouldn't think of
it then after three or four or five
times people would say
do you know anything about russia i kept
saying
after three or four times i said what's
going on with russia
they created a phony deal it was paid
for by hillary crooked hillary clinton
they made a phony russian
disinformation document oh and they used
it
to spy on you as a candidate correct
your transition team
and while you were president it says at
the top of
fisa warrant verified it was
unverifiable and they knew it 17 times
they knew it right from the get-go they
knew
they were worn beforehand and they knew
it certainly
from christopher steele and the
subsource by january total fraud
and you know what it did it hurt any
possibility
of dealing with russia we could have we
could have had a good
look they'll say oh he loves russia
getting along with russia is a good
thing not a bad thing getting along with
china is a good thing the problem we had
with china was covet
because nobody ever took out so much
money from china you know if you look at
china
i was taking tens of billions of dollars
of tariffs from china
and our farmers were doing great the
reason they were doing great was
because of the tariffs i was able to
sign a great deal for our farmers but
getting along with these countries
getting along with kim jong-un of north
korea
when i came in president obama said and
i think this is very public it's going
to
the biggest problem we have is north
korea there's going to be a war
there was no war we got along great he
writes some letters
i like him he likes me there's nothing
wrong with that
i got along great with president putin i
liked him he liked me
that's a good thing not a bad thing they
made up this
phony hoax just recently which came out
two days ago that it was a total phony
russian
it was a big deal in the campaign but
you know what it does it keeps you away
from these countries from dealing
economically we could have made a lot of
money they have great natural resources
we could have made a lot of money and
done well in jobs and everything else
getting along with russia is a good
thing getting along with these countries
is a good thing not a bad thing if i
were going to bet
there's probably a lineup now it sounds
like you're running it sounds like you
haven't lost any engagement
you've been very generous with the
attack thank you very much thank you all
right
and thank all of you for taking the time
to be with us